[Música]
no
hoy quiero contarles la historia de un
villano de un villano tan malvado que su
objetivo era privar de la libertad a un
tierno oso
y mucho
pero antes de contarles la historia de
este villano déjenme hablarles un poco
de chucho él es un tema actor ornatus
es decir un mozo anteojos y los osos de
anteojos son símbolo nacional de
colombia
hacen parte de la gran biodiversidad que
tenemos en el país sin embargo
son una especie vulnerable
por qué
hemos acabado con su ecosistema y pronto
será también una una especie en vía de
extinción dentro de dentro de este
contexto nace chucho en la reserva la
planada en nariño luego de unos años
pasa a la reserva natural de río grande
en caldas en la ciudad de manizales
donde pasan muchos muchos años bajo el
cuidado de una empresa prestadora de
servicios públicos de agua potable
luego de un tiempo la empresa junto con
la autoridad ambiental deciden que
buscar un sitio para que chucho pudiera
gozar de bienestar y aquí es donde entra
el zoológico de barranquilla quien luego
de cumplir toda una serie de
procedimientos administrativos y de
cumplir la ley y definirse que era el
mejor sitio para estar
el paso de manizales hasta barranquilla
en un largo viaje que estuvo que tuvo
una serie de inconvenientes entre ellos
uno que casi nos obliga a tener que
recogerlo en la mitad de una carretera
colombiana en un helicóptero de la
fuerza aérea
eso no pasó finalmente
chucho llegó a barranquilla muy bien y
la noticia pasó por toda colombia hasta
llegar a los oídos de un abogado quien
consideró que al oso al trasladarlo de
manizales a barranquilla se le estaban
negando su derecho a la libertad y por
esa razón entonces decidió echar mano de
una estrategia legal innovadora
solicitar un habeas corpus
y que es un haber cortes no me voy a
poner muy pesado con los temas jurídicos
pero igual hay una sola salida y está
vigilada así que no pueden ir para
ninguna parte me tienen que escuchar
un 'habeas corpus' es un derecho y un
mecanismo judicial reconocido
universalmente cuya finalidad es evitar
que el estado prive injustamente de la
libertad a las personas y esto funciona
bajo un principio denominado principio
pro homine es decir en favor de las
personas así que como así que un habeas
corpus en favor de un oso de anteojos
aquí es donde lo que quería hacer el
abogado
ir al formalismo y decir que el oso era
una persona y que el hábitat donde iba a
estar en el zoológico constituía una
cárcel y obviamente que el zoológico de
barranquilla era esta figura estatal que
estaba privando de la libertad al animal
y aquí es donde entra el villano un
abogado que junto con éste
maligno secuaz y con un equipo
interdisciplinario de biólogos
veterinarios y otros abogados de la
firma decidimos asumir la defensa del
oso y la defensa del zoológico para
evitar que lo dejáramos en libertad pero
antes de juzgar a estos villanos están
fuertemente le puede pedir que escuchen
la otra parte de la historia
creemos que chucho tiene unos 26 años
[Música]
es un animal que nació y se desarrolló
bajo protección humana es decir que
siempre ha necesitado de las personas
para poder obtener alimentos y
protección es un oso que lastimosamente
no puede ser retornado a su hábitat
natural porque sencillamente perdería
frente a la naturaleza
no pudo desarrollar esas habilidades
necesarias para combatir y para
desarrollarse
a pesar de que no teníamos tampoco una
historia clínica también teníamos claro
que el sitio donde estaba en la reserva
en manizales apc a pesar de ser
denominada una reserva natural ese
espacio que estaba ocupando eran
simplemente unos cuantos metros rodeado
de alambre de púas
sin ningún tipo de atención veterinaria
sin una dieta balanceada estaba en
sobrepeso y además estaba solo
por esta razón considerábamos que el
zoológico de barranquilla era el mejor
sitio para estar porque ahí estaba un
grupo de personas que durante más de 20
años habían trabajado en la protección y
la conservación de osos de anteojos
porque tendría ese grupo de veterinarios
y de biólogos que le iban a dar
bienestar y sobre todo porque iba a
poder compartir un espacio con una
hembra de su propia especie
con esta información decidimos entonces
aplicar todo el peso jurídico todo
todo el caparazón de la tradición legal
sin olvidarnos de lo importante del
bienestar del oso y de todo este
conocimiento científico que estaba
alrededor de lo que queríamos buscar era
efectivamente defender la vida de los
sin embargo llegó la sentencia de
segunda instancia a la corte suprema de
justicia donde aceptaron el habeas
corpus y fue una bomba fue una bomba que
nos decía que en 48 horas teníamos que
[ __ ] a chucho desde barranquilla y
llevarlo a manizales nuevamente
y esta sentencia adicionalmente de ser
esta bomba que nos ponía este tiempo
casi imposible de cumplir nos decía unas
cosas que eran muy reales y además casi
imposibles de refutar que las personas
somos un cáncer para el planeta que
además somos una especie hago ista y
completamente destructiva y que además
teníamos que cambiar inmediatamente la
forma de entender el mundo para pasar de
una idea antropocéntrica a una idea
excéntrica
la sentencia entonces para nosotros era
compleja como llegaron como pasaron
desde esa teoría a esta forma nueva de
entender el habeas corpus
en la que se indicaba que el oso al ser
un ser sintiente como dice la ley
también era una persona sujeta sujeto de
derechos que realmente eso no es lo que
dice la ley y sobre todo que esas
personas podían ejercer los derechos
ante los jueces como cualquier otro ser
humano
la sentencia evidentemente fue alabada y
fue aplaudida por muchas personas en el
país e internacionalmente sin embargo
nosotros que nos quedamos con la tarea
de cumplirle esta sentencia no teníamos
mucha claridad de cómo lo vamos a hacer
la decisión iba en contra del bienestar
del oso porque ya sabíamos que en
manizales no iba a tener el sitio
adecuado pero adicionalmente a eso
cumplir la sentencia en esas 48 horas en
ese formalismo propio y exclusivo del
habeas corpus
implicaba romper la ley colombiana y
además romper todos los protocolos
nacionales e internacionales sobre
bienestar animal y sobre cuidado y
traslado de estos animales
en últimas el 'habeas corpus' iba a
constituir una real sentencia de muerte
para los por esta razón entonces
decidimos tomar un reto este reto era
presentar una tutela en contra de la
decisión de habeas corpus y esta tutela
era un reto porque teníamos que ir ante
la misma corte suprema de justicia y
ponerlos a discutir sobre las decisiones
que habían tomado antes
que quisimos hacer aparte de toda la
fundamentación científica queríamos
plantear una discusión balanceada una
discusión en donde tanto el componente
estructural jurídico como el componente
científico se analizarán de forma pareja
entendiendo efectivamente que los
animales si tienen derechos pero que
esos derechos deben analizarse de otra
óptica desde la óptica de las
restricciones y de las obligaciones para
los hombres quienes somos los que
efectivamente podemos hacer y cumplir
las normas
también planteamos un problema de
representación quién puede exigir los
derechos de un oso y qué es el bienestar
animal nuestro caso era el perfecto
ejemplo para demostrar el peligro que
existía en abrir las puertas para que
cualquier persona sin ningún tipo de
conocimiento científico o técnico que
conociera la realidad de este oso
presentará un hábeas corpus y en últimas
le generará un daño
pero sobre todo queríamos tratar un tema
que para nosotros era importantísimo
y es un argumento que está en casi todos
las discusiones a favor de los derechos
de los animales y es que única y
exclusivamente le reconocemos derechos y
reconocemos personería a quienes se
parecen a nosotros como humanos los
ejemplos son muchos el gorila el gorila
se parece a nosotros entonces debe ser
considerado una persona el elefante es
suficientemente inteligente para ser
considerado persona todos estos son
pensamientos antropocéntricos y a
nosotros realmente nos preocupaba que
efectivamente se desarrollara una idea
contraria a lo que nos dice la ciencia y
es que todos los animales y todas las
especies deben ser respetadas por el
papel que juegan dentro de la naturaleza
por quiénes son dentro de la naturaleza
y no porque tanto se parecen a nosotros
y si revisamos la historia llegaremos a
la conclusión muy fácilmente de que
nosotros tenemos muy mala experiencia
o somos muy malos en definir quiénes
tienen derechos y quiénes no
en últimas lo que queríamos era evitar
convertir a chucho en un mártir en un
mártir de esa lucha que tienen algunas
personas por pelear los derechos
animales
llegó la sentencia de tutela también en
la misma corte suprema justicia y en
primera y en segunda instancia obtuvimos
una victoria
en una sentencia espectacular obviamente
todas las sentencias que son favorables
a los abogados todos van a decir que son
espectaculares pero realmente aquí sí
considerábamos que era una decisión
ponderada porque no solamente se
aceptaban todos nuestros argumentos y se
tenía claro el concepto de bienestar
animal sino que también
entendía el concepto de los seres
humanos como parte de la protección
animal como aquellos que estamos
obligados a proteger a los animales
y además esto nos ayudaba a entender un
concepto en el que venimos trabajando
desde hace mucho tiempo y es que los
cambios no se declaran los cambios se
tienen que construir paso a paso
fue una victoria hoy la sentencia está
siendo analizada por la corte
constitucional otra corte otra alta
corte colombiana por la relevancia del
tema en nuestra historia
y como les decía a pesar de ser una
historia era muy difícil no sentirse
villano obviamente como no nos íbamos a
sentir villanos si estábamos planteando
o estamos abogando por que alguien no
tuviera derechos o porque alguien no
fuera considerado persona que tan buenas
personas éramos nosotros que tan buenos
abogados eramos estábamos realmente del
lado correcto de la historia
sin embargo aquí entendimos una cosa muy
importante y es que la ley y los
derechos son victorias humanas no sobre
la naturaleza
sino sobre nuestros propios actos y yo
creo que aquí todos nos podemos sentir
orgullosos por saber que en algún
momento vencimos la tiranía de los reyes
constituimos una idea sobre el individuo
y una idea sobre la colectividad
desarrollando derechos fundamentales
derechos reconocidos universalmente
que logramos trabajar sobre el concepto
de igualdad y luchar contra aquellas
personas que querían destruir este
concepto que hoy podemos desarrollarnos
libremente
que hoy podemos expresarnos también
libremente que podemos decidir qué hacer
con nuestro cuerpo sin embargo todas
estas son victorias no sobre los
animales sino sobre unas historias
tenebrosas que han que han sido
protagonizadas por personas oscuras en
el mundo y que tenemos que tenerlas muy
claras porque hoy todavía se están
asomando asustados
considero que estamos en el momento de
la evolución del ser humano en el
desarrollo de las normas en favor y en
protección de los animales que tenemos
el conocimiento y que tenemos todas las
herramientas para poder evolucionar en
la creación de normas y de mecanismos
que sean efectivamente proteccionistas
de los animales bajo conceptos
innovadores lo que vayamos seiscientos
años atrás y cojamos un habeas corpus
y lo metamos dentro de los formalismos
sin tener en cuenta cuáles son las
realidades y cuáles son los problemas
que tenemos hoy en día
de manera que entonces nosotros mismos
nos elevemos para ver la la naturaleza
nuestra nuestra alto perdón que veamos
nuestra nos veamos nosotros en la
naturaleza y que la ley sea un reflejo
de esta naturaleza y no todo lo
contrario un mecanismo para cambiarla de
manera ineficiente
para concluir quiero invitarlos a que
actuemos a que nos llenemos de
conocimiento a que utilicemos todas las
herramientas que están en nuestro favor
para crear criterios y para fijar el
ritmo de nuestro comportamiento que con
este ritmo de comportamiento sin
importar que se conviertan en leyes de
la república o no con estas con este
nuevo comportamiento podamos crear
nuevos estándares y que estos estándares
que estén
con
con la gasolina de las aspiraciones
humanas nos permitan justo con el
conocimiento con las herramientas
tecnológicas y con las con los
conocimientos técnicos crear o fijar
unas bases para un mundo mejor y no nos
dejemos engañar no se dejen engañar por
nosotros a veces la ley no es propiedad
de los abogados todo lo contrario
el poder de crear un futuro 4.0 está en
nuestras propias acciones en que todos
nos reunamos a identificar cuáles son
nuestros problemas a crear nuevos
mecanismos y entender cómo nos
relacionamos en él en este mundo nuevo
y que podamos cambiar las bases de
nuestra sociedad para así poder crear
las normas del futuro y sobre todo que
siempre tengamos claro
que la esencia de la ley y de todos
nuestros derechos está en su
conocimiento muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]